[cough]
Hello everyone. Today we are taking a
small break from our hinged and
informational videos and we dive into a
realm where only the coolest of the cool
kids dwell. Very exclusive club we have
here actually just by choosing to click
into this video instead of the ones that
may actually change your life for the
better. Proves that you are special. And
speaking of special, it all started with
four mench children sitting at a bar
talking about magic. Of course, out of
nowhere, someone brought up Beyblades.
And turns out we all had come across
some videos about the most recent
Beyblade generation. For me, it was this
one by Distraction Makers. Excellent
video. It's cool and nostalgic, but we
knew we weren't going to be committed
enough to go fullon Beyblading,
especially with the little time we get
to meet. We'd rather magic. But another
idea was proposed using Beyblades to
determine the starting player in our EDH
games. And at that moment, we knew we
were going nowhere but up. Hello
everyone. This is Jyn with Next Level
Commander. And after a month or so of
exploring and researching, I finally
feel ready to bring you my guide to
using Beyblades to determine your EDH
starting order. If you want more
background information, the video by
Destruction Makers is excellent. And
also, I found out the Red Bobcat also
made a Beyblade video. And if you're
wondering why everyone is talking about
it now, here's the deal. In 2023, a new
generation was released called Beyblade
X. It brought new life to what was a
relatively stale game. They introduced a
new standard stadium which has this
extreme dash line designed to propel
Beyblades into each other at high
speeds. The new Beyblades also feature
more modernistic designs. Simple,
elegant, and pretty cool in my opinion.
It's something I never considered
playing before this, but the more I get
into it, the more it sounds like a
decent idea. So, why choose Beyblades
over something like Russian roulette or
musical chairs? Well, first, it's easy.
There is some skill involved like how
you launch and where you launch into the
stadium, but for the most part it's
about finding the best part combos and
also a lot of luck. Second, it's
relatively inexpensive. Head to your
local Walmart or GameStop, spend $105,
and you have a ready to go Beyblade.
Just a little more, you can get a
package of three for fall on battles.
Now, keep in mind the first Beyblade you
purchase should come with a launcher.
Otherwise, you you can play. The stadium
is a little more expensive, but if you
split it between, say, four friends is
really not much. Another reason to fit
this into your commander sessions is
that it's pretty fast. The rounds are
quick. Even if you choose to be thorough
with a four-point match, it should take
just about 10 minutes or less. Finally,
it's nostalgic for many of us who grew
up with these toys and card games that
went in and out of popularity, and now
it's more hype than it's ever been. Now,
the biggest obstacle is probably the
setting where to play. Beyblade isn't
quiet by any means, so it's best suited
for the kitchen table or your man cave.
This may also pass if your local game
store has a lively environment and
ideally can store a Beyblade stadium for
you. But just make sure about this
before you make your first purchase.
Okay, let's get started. Before we do
though, please keep in mind I'm fairly
new to this as well. Will I provide
enough information to set you on the
right path to begin exploring on your
own? Yes. Do I have enough insight to
get you to the World Championships? No.
So, we'll be doing this in parts. Step
one is something you probably don't care
much about, but it's very important to
me. Coming up with some pretentious
jargon to address our hobby. So, over
here, I think we're talking about
something cool rather than children's
toys. I was thinking babes, cuz you
know, Beyblades. Let's go pick up some
babes. But Alex shut that down real
fast. Yeah. Okay, never mind. I go do
some research. Apparently, they're just
called bass. And people who play with
Beyblades are bladers. That works. Now,
with that out of the way, let's get a
sneak peek at the rules. I wouldn't
worry too much about things like deck
building, tournament structures, but
knowing about the point system is nice
because it will allow you to choose the
type of Beyblade accordingly. Generally,
a game of Beyblade is played in multiple
rounds until one player reaches four
points. And different victories award a
different amount of points. For example,
the most typical victory is called a
spin finish where you simply outlast the
opponent and you will get one point this
way. But if you manage to burst your
opponent, yes, these beyblades are
designed to burst apart when you hit at
a certain angle with the right amount of
force. You will get two points. Another
way to get two points is when you knock
your opponent's Beyblade into one of
these two side pockets. And finally, if
you manage to get them over the wall
here, you get three points. And between
each round, you can swap out one
Beyblade for another. After trying out
some matchups, I have to say I'm a big
fan of this rule. The point system
combined with the stadium gimmicks
really rewards picking Beyblades that
are built for offense or even chaos,
preventing a slow slugfest, which used
to be one of the biggest problems with
older Beyblade generations. So, with
that in mind, let's talk a little bit
about the types. They're trying to build
this rock paper scissors metag game.
Attack beats stamina, stamina beats
defense, and defense beats attack with
the balance type sitting in the middle.
However, from my personal experience,
this doesn't quite play out the way they
want. I found that it's more like
Magic's case of who's the aggro. If you
see your opponent's Beyblade and you
know you're not going to outlast it, you
will be on the offense. So, you may be
launch at an angle for a more aggressive
movement. Honestly, that's more than
enough information for you to start
playing. Let's pick up a Beyblade. So,
my hot take here would be to not look at
the metag game. The meta for Beyblade is
a bit like commander where the vast
majority of decks lie between four to
seven on the old power skill. If we go
meta too quickly, things might get stale
and you lose the joy of exploration. In
fact, I'm going to quickly go over some
meta choices so you can actively avoid
them. If you don't want to be spoiled
about them, jump a minute to the next
section where I introduce some of the
coolest designs in the game. The first
one I would avoid is the, brace
yourselves, the wizard rod.
I know you're 15 and you want it for the
name, but hold off. Wizard Rod is the
ultimate stamina type that aims to force
every matchup into a lawn spinning
contest. Switch will be won by Wizard
Rod nine times out of 10. Silver Wolf
does something similar. The whole point
of this bay is to brush off contact and
be as defensive as possible. Actually,
that's it really. These two are the
stock combos that almost never lose to
anything else stock. There are certain
attack types that are also considered S
tier. You can look out for them. But
attack types add an element of
randomness and rely more on finding the
right pieces. So, if you just play them
stock and try to mess around with the
pieces on your own, chances are you're
going to have reasonably balanced games.
Aside from the aforementioned, you and
your friends can pick up pretty much
anything, whether you like the design or
the color or whatever, and have awesome
games. And here are some of the most
interesting designs from Beyblade X to
add to your collection. First of all,
one of my personal favorites, the Dran
Buster. This is the ultimate chaos
Beyblade with an imbalanced design
trying to knock people out with just one
attack focused on the tip. And once you
take the few initial shots, the game is
over whether you knock your opponent out
or not. The Dren Buster is never winning
any stamina contest. This one is called
Samurai Saber. has got these little tips
that extend out free spinning to provide
a bit more balance, but they retract on
contact for stronger impact. Scorpion
spear does something similar, feature a
relatively round shape at first, but the
moment it rides the extreme line, which
usually perceives impact, it turns into
a more aggressive smashing shape. Then
there's the night male, which has three
metal balls to help stabilize against
certain impact. And it also has a bouncy
tip. Not sure what that does, but it's
great for fidgeting. Impact Drake has
rubber pieces covering its points of
contact, which adds recoil and can
easily snuff out spin of the opposing
Beyblade, combining with its heavy
weight. This one here is called the
Cobalt Drake. Is currently the only left
spinning Beyblade cuz everything else
spins right. This allows it to steal
spin from the most persistent stamina
types. And it's not just these gimmicks.
A lot of the shapes are interesting as
well. For example, Golem Rock is just a
really compact, low to the ground
fortress that fends off whatever attack
you throw at it. Meanwhile, Phoenix Wing
has one of the most aggressive attacking
shapes. And on the opposite end of that,
we have the Ghost Circle is just a small
circle that dances around the stadium
hoping to avoid contact. And if you just
can't get enough of Univers's Beyond,
Beyblade is doing that, too. But yeah,
lots of choices. Now you have your
Beyblades, a stadium, and hopefully some
friends who you sent this video to and
are now in it together. I'd recommend a
mini tournament structure with two
semi-finals into a final. It really
doesn't take much time and is much
better than the alternative of four
people launching at the same time. That
might not be the best idea. Speaking of
not the best idea, do not overtighten
your launcher. Just wind the Beyblade
and when it feels resistance, stop.
Also, do not launch at people, pets, or
your opponent's magic cards. I know it's
tempting. Do not bring your face too
close to the stadium when battling.
These things can fly out. And there you
have it. Thank you for watching. Let me
know which Beyblade you choose. This is
Jyn with Next Level Commander, and I'll
see you in the next video.